hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and I said
on my community post on YouTube and I
tagged a lot of people on discord saying
that I wasn't going to do this video
because there wasn't a lot and you'll
understand what I mean by that but after
like an hour of thinking I said [ __ ] it
I kind of have an idea of what I
actually could talk about that's gonna
be about the new event we're gonna be
eating that at the very end of the video
but yeah that's why I wanted to redo the
video so if we saw the post that said I
wasn't going to make one and then I made
one anyway I do apologize for that
but as always like the VP do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes that hero updates
potentials and leaks if you want to be
kept up today with everything happening
within the world of foreigner and never
miss out an update deftly stay subscribe
to the channel my Twitter and discord
will be in the description down below if
you guys want to join those to be highly
appreciate it and with that let's get
started so as I said it for the actual
news today there really wasn't a lot
there's going to be a new event
challenge I believe it's a slayer with
the faction with the most amount of
takedowns for the weekend when some
rewards could be still could be XP I do
believe it's steel or scavenger crates
we're going to be having the usual
Arcade Quest every week so that's really
nice if you want to hop on that maybe
get some of the new effects that we've
had like the tessellated aura which I
believe is anyone for season 10 and then
the other ones from the past I do
believe you could still get those but I
couldn't be totally wrong and then the
last thing for today is gonna be the new
content of the week and that is the
elite outfits they're gonna be 7000
steel each and I believe it's faction
different so of course that one's the
elite outfit for the Nights is gonna be
very different for the Vikings so yeah
go into your character whatever you want
to pick if you want to pick these elite
outfits they're okay but their lead
outfits they're never really been great
I usually say my steel for mythix or
masks anyway but going on to the last
part of the video now this is something
that wasn't talked about in the stream
but I do have some facts and possibly
some information that I believe no just
based off of assumptions and
speculations that could actually be true
and I want to talk about that and that
is I want to talk about the new event
coming this season and as you may know
every single season this year which is
seasons 9 10 11 and 12 currently were in
season 10 every one of them is going to
have some type of event and if it
follows the trend we will beginning an
event around the lore of the current new
hero of that season last season we had
black Pryor's were passed which was the
new event dedicated to the
or in the backstory of the new hero
black prior or Vorta gir whatever you
want to call him and how they came to
the battlefield
what battles they fought and many other
things about their character during this
event we got tons of stuff like the
usual outfits emotes new pets new
weapons and a whole lot more which is
what I already covered in a past video
months ago but what about this season
heat so kiri or Sakura is known as a man
Slayer according to the post on the 4 on
her webpage but it also translates to
executioner or assassin I'm thinking
this is gonna revolve around that
somehow the last season the new map
Harbor was also changed into a Blood
Moon with lots of dark tones I do
believe that was the only map changed
throughout that event so I'm assuming
the new map canopy is also going to be
changed to fit this new theme and it's
gonna be a whole new event playlist for
the entire for the entire event which is
gonna be really cool to see as for what
the new theme might be so far with these
new Harvard injures they've been very
brutal and monsterous killing machine so
I'm expecting another similar style to
this season we're probably going to be
getting the same type of content like
outfits weapons emotes the usual
possibly even get more pets or maybe
even a whole new thing altogether a lot
of people were talking about weapon
effects because the Star Wars event that
happened a couple weeks ago so that
might be that may have just been a test
to see if they could pull it off with
the new event and I for one would love
to see that in game as for the release
day I'm just gonna be speculating that's
gonna be coming out in the next couple
weeks or so going off of season 9 that
was about a month into the season and
roughly were almost about a month into
the season I do believe that season 10
started roughly I think end of April or
early May I believe so seeing as we're
heading into June we're gonna be around
that one month mark so I'm assuming
early June maybe mid June is where we're
going to be getting the new season as
for what it entails we don't know it's
probably gonna be talked about on the
next couple warriors then it's leading
up to it maybe the one before it or
maybe the one that is the day of but
I'll keep you guys up to date with all
that news when it comes out yeah guys
it's gonna be the end of the bait say
hopefully you guys did enjoy it let me
know your thoughts on the new event let
me know what you guys think what could
be part of the new event any lore about
the character that could be put into the
new event because obviously these these
events are always about the lore of the
character so they're gonna try to
incorporate some things they might also
incorporate some big samurai battles
that happen in the faction war cuz
that's also what they did for last
season for the Knights when they were
Serano Denault
besides and still managed to hold off
the one point that's why harbor was made
because it was around an ocean e dock
area so I'm wondering with the samurai
one will be just let me know all of your
thoughts on what you think or what you
would like to see in the new event in
the comments down below
but like the B if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being balanced changes here updates
Patchett's and leaks if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening within the world the foreigner
I never miss out an update deftly says
subscribe to the channel my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out would be highly appreciated my
Twitter and discord to be in the
description down below as usual
so that also behind me appreciate if you
check those out and take care guys enjoy
the rest of your day and peace out
[Music]